semble pas que ça a été voté tout s'est
fait très vite manuel olivier vivaient
ensemble depuis deux ans il avait envie
de légaliser leur union mais pour la
beauté et la force du symbole pas pour
les avantages qu'ils allaient avec
car dans les faits leur statut de pacsés
n'a pas changé grand chose ou si peu si
j'ai une mutuelle obligatoire et j'ai pu
prendre ou manuelle avec roy voilà nous
avons parce que le que le pacs donc on a
économisé 2000 from you tube ans plus
tard quand leur pack sera trois ans ils
pourront aussi éventuellement décider de
faire une déclaration de revenus commune
mais pour le reste la loi ne présente
que très peu de bénéfices concrets pour
beaucoup de lourdeur et d'imprécisions
la volonté délibérée de ne pas pouvoir
prêter le flanc à une quelconque
comparaison avec le mariage a abouti à
un choix qui n'était certainement pas le
meilleur
juridiquement parlant notamment dès que
des biens sont en jeu alors que les
couples mariés ont le choix entre un
régime de communauté ou de séparation de
biens
le régime de l'indivision par défaut
s'impose aux pacsés tous les biens
acquis par l'un ou l'autre pendant le
pacs meubles voitures ou actions sont
supposés appartenir aux deux mêmes sans
volonté explicite de leur part
et c'est là où commencent les litiges en
cas de rupture de pacs la séparation
comme celle que vit cet homme peut alors
être très mal vécu
quand vous voyez la penderie était à lui
donc il l'a remporté à l'admission
c'était et demi et tout ce que contient
cet appartement est aujourd'hui objet de
conflit entre les deux hommes
nous avons été pacsée pendant
effectivement à peu près trois mois à la
fin difficile
c'est donc une histoire d'amour qui
finit mal avec en prime un flou
juridique qui envenime la situation
alors qu'ils étaient encore pacs et
frédéric et son ami ont acheté une
voiture et il est parti avec donc il a
déposé plainte pour le vol des clés donc
en fait la voiture d'après mon avocat
nous appartient à tous les deux donc ce
serait plutôt moi qui devrais et a
réclamé la voiture une semaine sur deux
ou un jour sur deux où il ya un grand
flou d'autant que l'assurance était à
mon nom la carte grise aux siens donc
c'est vrai que c'est assez
frédéric fériés n'est pas pour autant
dégoûté du pacs les couples homosexuels
n'ont pas d'autres fois pour entériner
leur union mais la prochaine fois il
s'assurera de faire préciser chaque
point du contrat par un notaire à moins
que d'ici là la loisne et évoluer